hay seis personas en tu familia y cada
persona bebe cuatro quintos del galón de
leche cada mes entre qué números enteros
esté el número de galones de leche que
tu familia bebe cada mes y para ello
vámonos a otra pantalla donde podamos
hacer nuestras anotaciones ok y aquí
tengo mi galón de leche vamos a tomar
los datos que nos están dando tenemos
que en la familia hay seis miembros
vamos a ocupar seis miembros y cada
miembro bebe cuatro quintos de galón
cuatro quintos de galón esta será una
multiplicación donde seis miembros cada
uno beberá cuatro quintos de galón de
leche y la manera en la que podemos
pensar esto va a ser la siguiente vamos
a pensar en hacer la multiplicación
veamos tendríamos
seis por cuatro quintos o lo que es
igual pudiéramos pensar en cuatro
quintos seis veces cuatro quintos
cuatro quintos más cuatro quintos
creo que están tomando la idea cierto
más cuatro quintos más cuatro quintos
con eso tenemos seis veces cuatro
quintos y si sumamos cuatro quintos seis
veces tendremos 4 8 12 16 20 24 24
quintos ahora vemos que este número el
numerador es mayor que el denominador
cuántas veces cabe el 5 en el 24 pues
tenemos la opción de que quepa cuatro
veces exactas lo que es decir 20 quintos
y tendremos un residuo de 44 quintos lo
que es igual a 20 entre 54 enteros
cuatro quintos
vamos bien otra forma en la que podemos
pensar esto es tengo
enteros 6 sobre 1 x o quintos
y la forma en la que haremos esto es
bueno ya hicimos aquí cuatro más 444 más
44 tenemos 6
en tren
5 o lo que es lo mismo multiplicaremos
numerador por numerador
por 4
y multiplicaremos denominador por
denominador
1 por 5
y de esta manera hacemos nuestra
multiplicación 6 por 4 24 1 por 5
5 y volvemos a llegar al número mixto
donde tenemos 4 enteros
cuatro quintos así es que si nos
preguntan entre qué número y que el
número estaremos tomando de leche al mes
tendremos entre 4 y 5 galones porque
aquí tenemos un pequeño residuo vamos
entonces a nuestra respuesta
entre 4
y 5
comprobemos y es correcta